as soon as it goes 21 we're 21 go live
there we go
hello folks hey guys welcome to rational
science
we have a great day today
and we're going to be talking a little
bit about extinction followed by physics
and then opening the que the flora for
questions okay so let's get started with
some of the subject matters related to
extinction okay let me go with this see
we can go through it fast uh here my son
will control me
so that i don't uh spend too much time
fellow says what is blowing up is
marxism okay marxism is blowing up yeah
yeah and capitalism capitalism has one
in china
see you can see china is now blue and
it's the united states which this fellow
argues is going to be red or israel
uh where the new empire will rise
post-2030s
so he predicts that after 2030 uh china
is going to be the new empire and it's
not going to be communist it's going to
be i guess capitalists right
marxism is blowing up in europe right
now will blow up in the next 10 years
the governments have gone along because
of the great collapse in confidence in
government trump
i guess uh follows into uh politics a
lot okay
and he says collapsing marks his
promises all based on borrowed money
they plan on defaulting on okay so they
borrow a lot of money they're going to
default and what's going to happen well
he says extinctions of governments are
inevitable
okay
uh is this what's going to happen if if
we have an extension of government okay
uh what's going to replace it uh
government
the next one i mean that's kind of how
it's always worked revolutions right is
that what it is we we get but nobody's
saying it's the extension of government
governments as such like there's not
going to be any
after that is what he's saying yeah yeah
just anarchy
yeah but it's uh it's a polite anarchy
it's not the guy with the uh with a
molotov cocktail it's no such thing as
no government
no because i mean that's just how human
beings are even back in the day when
there's clans you can't i mean
it's far-fetched they call it government
but it's a form of government it's a
form of how do you organize 8 billion
people that's what we're talking about
well what if everybody governs himself
i guess that's what he's saying he said
everybody just does his own thing
without any law
governing him he just does it because
it's the right thing to do i guess and
if someone commits a crime i don't know
who takes care of that i know the uh
uh
anarcho-capitalists say well there you
can resolve that also through marketing
uh
mechanisms
you know how you punish someone maybe
punish
the person through money through his
pocket
so i don't know what comes after no
government uh they never talk about that
but yeah i know at least they don't go
in any great detail marx also said this
by the way you know uh the idea was that
you know we were going to get this world
government uh
taken there by um what is it called the
dictatorship of the proletariat once you
reach that point you get rid of
government altogether because you find
out that you don't need it and what
continues from there on forever and ever
is anarchy anarchy in the best sense of
the words meaning no government
whatsoever this guy says when the
government's gone we'll go back to the
shire the science from lord of the rings
where the hobbits go
okay let's go friendly friendly with
each other okay let's continue imagine a
person who has so much food they could
never eat it before it perishes you
don't think they will
they would trade any of it for anything
at all nonsense
why didn't trade run to a complete halt
when all other
fiat currencies in the past died bill
well they didn't die because they didn't
all die at the same time see when the
dollar dies that's it for all of us
because all currencies are essentially
pegged to the dollar okay i would trade
food for an object if i thought the
object could get me more food soon
not after the final collapse after the
final collapse if you trade you're
trading your life for the example trade
a fish for a rival round you can kill a
deer uh i i think that trade will be
done against your will you know what i
mean
you'll get the rifle round
my god
you'll get the rifle right he'll get the
fish trust me
oh yeah you come from the right you're
the one who put the egg in there
you're looking for a bullet i got yeah i
got it with your name on it right here
okay i said you said you cannot stop
people from trading this is in direct
contradiction to your theory that trade
will fail because money fails okay
according to your black market facts
trade will continue regardless of what
happens to the money in use today um
yeah i said i gave the example of cuba
where people despite it they're in a
communist country they have all this
black market out there and the trade is
primarily for food which is interesting
right
and uh so here's my answer can't stop
people from trading as long as the
global economy is running as long as the
cuban peso is still out there on the
streets uh yeah there's gonna be trade
it's the question what happens when
money is no more will there will there
be trade
i mean sometimes i try to think back of
just historical times how did they trade
back in the day
when there was no money when we were
just talking about bargaining
subsistence farming came into commercial
farming that's when uh they started
trading you know a guy did uh was a
better carpenter or whatever traded
before then
uh there was a question here's the
question was there in the history of
humanity
ever a time period where there were
where it was bartering
without any
money yeah in fact you can see it in the
bible if the story of ruth okay if you
look up the story of ruth the book of
ruth in the bible she worked for barley
she put her work she traded her labor
collected barley and part of that party
was that she collected part of that was
used to pay for her and her
mother-in-law which she also maintained
okay so yeah there was a time where
uh people work for food but it's always
under the umbrella of government you
can't yeah of course free trade in the
sense of like no government trade why
wouldn't i just shoot why would the guy
with the bigger gun not just take it
well that's the question i i think uh
what the way it developed is that you
know uh this farmer was over here the
other wood farmer was over there maybe a
lot of them were relatives clans or
whatever and from there what developed
was you know oh you do this better than
me why don't you give me your chair that
you made you're a better carpenter and
i'll give you some corn for it so first
it was within people you trusted
obviously it had to be
either an extended family or
neighbors that for some reason you
eventually managed to trust and you know
the little villages developed the tribes
you know how did the indians do it the
indians you know american indians for
example uh
they developed their societies and you
say how did this guy
at some point decide to trust that other
guy over there
and you know it had to be at some point
where you know that trust developed
because they settled the land they they
started maybe farming or even hunting
and they
for some reason did not shoot at each
other
yeah yeah i don't think that happened i
think it was always under the umbrella
of
one big muscle guy saying hey guys play
nice i.e the police
there was always a form of police going
around there has to be
peace before there's trade that's what
i'm saying within the clan i can
understand that perfectly at all
no no but i mean within the clan
especially right uh we can imagine that
there's this uh
alpha guy i guess
yeah kind of guy and he set down the law
and those that were weaker said okay
we'll follow that law i think it's it's
good for me for myself
and so
from there i think that's where law came
into being government came into play but
i'm just saying the difference between
what this guy is saying i'm saying the
end of the world kind of anarchy anarchy
and trade don't mix that's what i'm
saying
because you have to have
peace you have to have no guns before
there's trade there has to be
that repercussion if you uh
you know renege on the trade or mess up
the trade or something there must be
consequences
or
they have to at least
be certain that you're not just going to
shoot them and take the stuff yeah it's
kind of like a like a illegal drug deal
kind of things like like yeah yeah yeah
where they have the the the the pounds
of cocaine and the other days got the
millions of dollars or whatever and
when's it
one does not come up with with the goods
not only that but you never see them
come with no ak-47s because then the
other guy just oh
thank you
that's what i'm saying or or they both
come with a cable yeah just just to make
sure to make sure it's enough make sure
it's even exactly it's an even deal
trade and anarchy just don't don't
really mix okay regarding family we have
here get rid of social security and then
one of the reasons to have kids
magically reappears okay so he says uh
the pro i stated it in a different way i
said if the state won't take care of you
when you're old you better start having
kids that's essentially what he's saying
he says the laws are the problem instead
of the uh cities
um
yeah
remember
it's one of the
reasons that we stop having kids is that
the state takes care of the old as well
as of the kids social security made us
sterile that's kind of that's a yeah
it's one of the factors okay but it's
not the most important factor
the the most important factor is we move
from the country to the cities okay and
that's the main one
okay another fellow along the same lines
similar says women don't have high
school degrees have more kids
who don't have high school degrees have
more kids or babies
in very rural areas we have more parents
at home school there is no school bus
for them significant family traits are
taught in that environment
in government-run public schools there
isn't much of a presence in family
values that's true okay but uh so
what i'm what am i going to say to that
well let me say the following i'm saying
that um
family has changed through the ages okay
hunter gathering we had the clans
uh era of farming maybe ten thousand
last ten thousand years we had uh
patriarchy uh man of the house he was
the head of the household he had power
of life and death where everyone from
the slaves
to
uh to the
to the wife okay
and then manufacturing we ended up with
the nuclear family essentially mom and
pop and the kids and today we have the
singles society the bachelors we don't
marry or we're all divorced or uh you
know we're just um
casual
actually hold it on a nice picture yeah
another thing that i was thinking of was
just now
they're talking about the family values
not being so precedent or not being so
prevalent yeah so prevalent in in modern
schools and i think it's take it's gone
even a step further like the further
back you go in time here contour
gathering is pure family values and then
it becomes more about the
society and less about family as you go
to the right
and now we have the extreme case where
children are really being raised by the
internet and have no family values
yeah but then i want you to see
something else there in in that grab you
see that when we started in hunter gansu
it was the many and today we ended up
with a few yeah it's gotten smaller
smaller and smaller over the years yeah
yeah yeah so uh the question is what
comes after bachelor after singles
the nuns
we're already there
i know any
okay continuing on here again people say
people come to the cities to create
wealth
okay
wealth is what reduces populations and
that is why the poorest nations have the
highest birth rates and the richest
nations have the lowest birth rates
well i'm going to counter that i'm going
to say that this is not true and this is
a very widespread misconception that
people have out there not only this fall
but a lot of people have this idea so
here's my idea to oppose that okay here
you see it looks like a correlation
in in the 19th century it was the filthy
rich who had kids
okay i hope to destroy the notion that
it was today because we see poor people
having kids in the cities we say oh it's
the poor people
it used to be the rich people who had
kids in fact uh that last one the
yellowish
one there you know who that is that's uh
israel in his 12
sons
because he was a rich guy
he could afford them he had someone to
bequeath the land to the sheep and all
the stuff he had that's why he had many
kids because he was a farmer and it's
when we went to the cities
uh that we stopped having kids not so so
it's the
uh
fallacy of you know i drink uh beer with
water
and it gets me drunk i drink with wine
with water it gets me drunk i drink
whiskey with water it gets me drunk so
it's water that's getting me drunk
that's the correlation mistake yeah and
and uh and people here commit the same
error they say oh it's the poor people
who have kids it's got nothing to do
really with the poor people it's the
poor people who came from the farms they
have no jobs in the cities they either
bring their kids from the
from the country because they just came
to the city or they have a you know
still the culture of the of the country
and they bring that in there until they
realize you know especially their the
next generation their kids they realize
you can't have kids anymore in the
cities okay so it's the city that stops
the
children from coming up not so much the
fact that they're poor rich why don't
rich people have children
okay in the cities okay
why did they happen in the 19th century
that makes more sense
okay
another issue uh i mentioned this the
other day where we have the uh
man who turned himself into a woman a
fellow in red there you can see he looks
pretty much like a man
and he changes sex when he was over 30
that means he spent his whole life as a
man and then he snipped it off turned
himself into a woman and now fights and
fights women in his category and he's
beating the crap out of them and some
women don't like that you know so i
mentioned this the other day and uh
you know and i said well when we have
unisex sports where we stop separating
men from women and we have everybody
compete against everybody in every
single sport in other words whether it's
soccer american football wrestling
boxing kickboxing whatever you can think
of especially the rough sports everybody
against everybody no more female no more
male okay so we don't have to worry
about this and a fella replies says well
they can never win because they don't
have testosterone
the
okay well i don't know about that i'm
sure that if we take some of these girls
who uh do kickboxing and some i'm sure
they can beat the crap out of this fall
okay and so he's got testosterone
they've got estrogen but i'm sure you
know that if he fights one of these gals
that is well trained i think she would i
put my money on her
now uh so why am i saying this i'm
saying this uh because what i showed the
other day is that women have come up the
ranks okay and here you see it you see
this is 1936 the 100 meter dash it was
won by a fellow which is famous his name
is jesse owens or where's jesse owens
second guy was also ralph metcalf
another american both of them black
and uh
the third record if if they were to run
in 1936 again i would you know it would
be florence griffith who's got the
women's world record today right
and she would come in third and she
would beat uh this other fella ocean
darp
and after him it would have come uh this
the gal who won this year who's elaine
thompson
and she would have beaten the other
three guys all white by the way
uh
which have uh records which are lower
than hers
okay so women have come up the ranks
over time they have um
become faster that's in 1936 yeah 1936
so the question now isn't any more
yeah no but this is the point the point
that is you're giving women enough time
will they match men this vowel says no
because they don't have testosterone
well apparently testosterone has
i don't know i'm suggesting right
playing devil's advocate here maybe it's
got nothing to do with it because here
you have women who would have beaten men
in the 1930s right today right and if we
give them another 100 years
maybe they're at the par with men maybe
it's got nothing to do with testosterone
and estrogen we just think of women as
the weak sex
and again there's some women out there
that can beat the crap out of many men
so i don't know about the weak sex
really weird to see yeah but i mean uh
just giving enough time
yeah i don't think so well
i'm suggesting it because i'm saying if
everybody competes against everybody
right no we don't have to worry about
women women well yeah because uh the end
of the world is near but i know i mean
you don't have to worry about like
genders or any of the trends yeah if we
do sports unisex no more of this olympic
for women and olympic for men we just
let everybody compete against everybody
will women come up the ranks and i mean
after all i'll give you an example his
name is bruce jenner today he changed
his name and a little more than that
right and he was the decathlon winner
i can't remember the year but he won the
gold medal
and
he thought himself as a woman now you
know i'm sure there's going to be a lot
of arguments here on all sides defending
and attacking my point here is
uh
this guy at least thought he he was a
woman he thought as a woman or thinks as
a woman
and he beat the crap out of a lot of men
out there so um
just food for thought okay okay uh phil
says women have influenced their
husbands throughout history yeah and
there we have a case in point uh
uh who was it eve they weren't married
though
yeah but uh sex out of wedlock
but see what's in a ring yes you married
him she convinced uh adam to take the uh
to take the bite
is there always a woman they say there's
a woman behind every successful man
that she's the one who uh
you know kind of pulls the strings
or at least uh
influences him significantly
okay another
issue money what is money well we had
different uh people uh talk about what
money is one guy says the most saleable
good what saleable mean uh well that i
guess that you can trade it easier you
know it's liquid right and but he
defines currency as counterfeit money
that's what that's why he says that
money is not the same thing as currency
because currency is counterfeit money
fake money okay monopoly money okay he's
saying currency is like the
representation of wealth well he's
saying that currency is what we have in
the in the what you trade what you
really give in exchange i guess right uh
again it's not very specific so we can't
make sense of that but anyways current
another fellow says currency is money
that is being used or is in circulation
okay money is something used as a way to
pay for goods and services and to pay
people for their work another fellow
says something similar says bank account
money is beans used to pay salaries buy
groceries pay rent and as long as it's
used for goods and services it keeps
circulating in the economy and paying
for many different things okay
and another says money is debt okay
being an owner means being a subject
that pays tribute to the state
so a lot of seniors years old yeah so
people have a lot of different notions
of what money is money is no longer you
know what we always thought it is
apparently not to everybody everybody
has a different
uh perspective my perspective money is
like a favor
a favor it's a favor that goes around
okay i i give you paper you give me a
favor you give that the next guy
that paper he gives you a favor that guy
you it's just a fake it's it's favor is
going one way bill's going
i i see it differently i say money is
what it says on that dollar bill in god
we trust money is trust that's all it is
once we lose faith when we lose trust
that you're going to get a favor
or
something in exchange yeah whatever okay
but my point here is that
money is trust you trust that the other
guy is going to give you something or
has given you something in your hand or
promises to give you something and you
accept that promise right
because what is the dollar it means that
you can take it to someone else you
trust that that other guy is going to
accept it as well but when we lose that
trust what is the value of money zip how
weird would it be if you go to the
supermarket to buy some apples and
they're like oh sorry sorry we don't
accept money money
do this experiment okay uh trust me okay
just take some vietnamese money into
your supermarket and see if they accept
it and if they say no you say quote it's
it's money it's backed by the government
of vietnam
we don't accept that disney money
we accept i thought money was money
well it doesn't seem like it okay
continuing here
uh the money supply increases when banks
make loans and decreases when borrowers
uh pay principal back to the banks okay
fractional reserve banking is how banks
make new money okay the federal reserve
prints money based on
nothing
and fellow clarifies here the world's
current monetary system became
debt-based after the nixon shock what is
he talking about talking about in which
president nixon suspended the link
between money and gold in 1971.
is that in concrete language that you
can't you can't turn in money for gold
anymore uh yeah let me clarify that here
in fact this is what it is
it's important for people to know this
the bretton woods system of monetary
management dating to 1944 established
the rules for commercial and financial
relations
the chief features of the bretton wood
system were an obligation for each
country to adopt a monetary monetary
policy that maintain its external
exchange rates within one percent by
tying its currency to gold the united
states which controlled two-thirds of
the world's gold insisted that the
bretton woods system rest on both gold
and the us dollar on 15 august 1971 the
united states unilaterally terminated
convertibility of the us dollar to gold
effectively bridging at bringing the
bretton woods system to an end and
rendering the dollar a fiat currency the
bretton wood system was over by 1973
the subsequent era was characterized by
floating exchange rates
in other words what happened was uh the
gold standard was taken out
you know and today uh essentially what
we have is what is known as a floating
system meaning that all currencies are
pegged to each other essentially all of
them are pegged to the dollar
if you want to look at it that way but
they're all pegged to each other meaning
you can create like this fellow just
said
as much money as you can't want because
you don't have to
you don't have to match it with
something that exists in reality right
you don't have to men you don't have to
peg it to the supply of gold that's out
there gold has no value in that sense
anymore in fact gold
uh you could say it has an intrinsic
value because you can do things with
gold right but uh gold has money
it has no value it has as much value as
anything else yeah it's a rock if you
want to accept it fine but the day we
lose confidence in
money
meaning all kinds of money from bitcoin
all the way to gold to
not food food food is good good money
always but nobody will trade it once the
whole things collapses but gold diamonds
the jewels no value whatsoever okay uh
in fact make computers out of them yeah
in fact you have computers you have cars
you have ships all the airplanes all
that has value today but when money
collapses you won't accept a ship you
will not accept an airplane you will not
accept the car
unless unless
uh it comes full of
food bend your legs nothing
but otherwise you won't accept it what
are you gonna do with an airplane if uh
what are you gonna fly around and see if
you can find some food somewhere
[Laughter]
okay uh here's uh another people falsely
give money value there is no value in
money itself correct i like trade for
what it what is valuable rather than
using a measurement based on a fairy
tale there are current lifestyles that
have little use for money
currently okay again lifestyle you can
have all that uh
as long as uh
the whole system doesn't collapse when
the system collapses
everybody's gonna come to all those
people who live without money like you
know what are we talking about we're
talking about hunter gatherers out there
farmers right there's only three people
who live without money it's it's
hunter-gatherers like people who live in
the woods yeah uh people who have
subsistent farming for themselves which
are also weirdos and like fringe people
and i guess monks would be the last one
people would just like
nomads nomads uh you know like the
bedouins uh they go around with their
camels
of course they buy things and sell it
but it doesn't amount to even one
percent of the population no of course
not uh that's true but this is the point
the point is when the whole system
collapses now you got to worry about
defense
and so if you're if you've got a farm
your farm is going to be overrun no my
defense is you eat your food as fast as
you can
there's nothing here
there's nothing to steal yeah but then
you're out of luck as well
okay related
here we have uh fellas bill gates paid
someone in the wuhan
lab to release the virus with carl
schwab's blessing okay and another
fellow says why would china create the
bug to collapse the western economy and
re release it in wuhan totally illogical
and that's why you know i uh came up
with the copic flow chart the other day
okay this is the reasoning
okay go something like this uh you gotta
answer the question would cuba iran and
other enemies of the american empire
come cooperate with the us in a hoax
okay
and if you say yes well you know i've
got problems with you and i think we
remove your right to vote okay and if we
continue are there people so mean and
greedy that they would have created the
bug to take over the world
and if you say yes uh
i have a
mfc if you say no i have a tall building
in new york that i'd like to sell you
okay yeah there are mean people out
there okay but uh so the the issue here
is would china be complicit in a hoax in
light of the fact that it intends to be
the next empire okay so i doubt very
much that china would cooperate with the
united states i think they are competing
and to think that they would all come up
with this hoax in every country of the
world
okay
especially the big guys uh china
russia and the united states that all
these
uh the heads of those
three countries would agree
to in in advance to say hey why don't we
create a virus and scare everybody in
the world to death and then we can
implement these laws where we can
control them a lot better blah blah blah
blah blah blah
i don't think i don't think china would
cooperate in such a thing if china is
trying to take over yeah i think
everything we can all see that they
could have adapted to the situation but
it still caught them off guard but it's
not that from from coming into the
situation they're already planning okay
guys
us we all we all agree on this we're
gonna let this go and wuhan
that'd be kind of weird that's where i
have a problem and until someone can
answer that question you know i i don't
think that you can talk about a hoax
you got to justify the hoax and the hoax
the way you justify the hoax is saying
would all these enemy countries agree in
advance
to
to
talk about this cove it and invent it
out of nowhere besides are so messy you
can't really plan very well
when you're talking about a virus a
pandemic because there's you don't know
what the
what the
edges are
like like that's a bad uh
conspiracy if i wanted to do a
conspiracy okay assuming there was
something to gain okay
throwing a pandemic is a bad idea
because you don't know how powerful
it'll be you don't know how many
countries it'll reach you don't know
what you don't know what the consequence
is yeah you can't control it it's too
yeah you can't control it which is like
it doesn't seem like a good foundation
to get any benefit from
or at least there are better uh things
people would come up with yeah
and again i i doubt very much this is my
argument that all enemy countries would
agree to us that's the way and so that's
the one you got to answer if you can
answer that then i'll say that it's a
hoax okay but until then i have to
believe that this virus
apparently is real okay some people
apparently are dying of this
okay fellas a cell is not the smallest
life okay the issue is not smallest i'm
saying uh that the cell
jump real quick what do you mean cells
now you mean cell is the small is not
the smallest
thing that we can call life
well that's this is the what i want to
clarify here that i'm saying that cell
is the first or or the first unit of
life okay that doesn't mean it's the
smallest i wasn't talking about smallest
even though i think we have a match
there i think it is the smallest as well
but this guy continued says the smallest
life unit is that i think he met
protists
and he says protit okay or microzyma
which emerges from dead cells to perform
cleanup
okay so let's find out what he's talking
about okay here canada's cells
okay so this is where we start on this
uh here's the
miasma theory and this was the theory
that governed uh most of medicine i
guess world until 19th century
and it came from
galen and even before them hippocrates
and they said diseases such as cholera
and bubonic plague are caused by a
miasma okay
pollution
okay a noxious form of bad air how far
they thought it was a bad air yeah
floating in in the
in the atmosphere okay uh miami
poisonous vapor or mist filled with
particles from decomposed matter that
caused illness okay it's not that far
from the truth is it well uh let's find
out uh
what came after was uh from mr luis
pasteur and he came up with germ theory
okay and that replaced this miasma
theory and it goes more or less like
this it's what we have today essentially
that's what all the doctors believe in
or this is what they're taught this is
what they learned is what they teach
okay more or less like mathematical
physics it's
grounded in stone now
microorganisms uh can lead to disease
okay so we have these small organisms
they invade the human body and other
animals uh their growth and reproduction
within the host caused the disease okay
essentially it's what most of us
uh intuitively or have read somewhere
you know that's what we all essentially
are educated to believe okay
okay let's move on because uh here we
have this other foul who opposed louis
pasteur he was a contemporary
okay his name was antoine bechamp okay
also a french guy both of these were
french
and he came up with a micro zymian
theory and which is what this fellow is
referring to and
he had a different theory which is no
longer accepted today but it's good to
know
uh that this theory is around because a
lot of people believe more or less along
the same lines as mr b champ okay
tiny molecular granulations known as
microzymas okay small ferments he called
them like that because they
tended to ferment sugar okay
uh that have been observed in the cells
of plants and animals are living
elements he said there is something
living which is smaller than the cell in
fact it's a part of the cell
survives after the death of the organism
microzyma is a building destroyer of
cells it precedes life at the cellular
level microzymas are very sensitive to
biological signals responding to changes
in the terrain in other words the
environment okay especially ph he says
when the terrain becomes compromised the
microzymas change into microscopic forms
it turns into my bacteria okay that
contributes to the development of
illness be champ uh pleomorphic theory
considers the internal environment as
the most important contributing
factor
to the microscopy must turn into
bacteria so these precede even bacteria
yeah yeah so this is kind of weird
because i don't know about microzyma's
uh turning into bacteria but this is
more or less the theory uh according to
b champ
these
microsynonyms were part of the cell
when the cell dies the microcymus never
die
so i guess he was talking about
molecules and not about living entities
but he called them or he believed that
they were living entities
and uh you know
what affected the microzymas the
environment
so the theory was that it was a disease
that got you sick and killed you it was
these microzymas which survived the cell
and
because of the environment they
triggered something within your body
so it's what a lot of people believe
today that it's the environment that
affects you that's what we
eat and what we uh
breathe and you know this pollution out
there so a lot of people believe in that
stuff even today and that comes really
from b champ it's like we've reinvented
him or he never died like the microzymas
and uh all i can tell you is that the
establishment medical establishment does
not accept that theory everybody
believes in or more more or less
most i'd say 99 of the doctors out there
believe in the germ theory they go along
with mr louis pasteur
okay so that's food for thought there's
not a big difference between them isn't
there well one says it's the environment
and the other fellow says no it's the
disease but it includes the journal no
no no but this is what he was saying
saying there's something
in the germs themselves in this case the
cell okay
uh because you you could have a germ
like bacteria is a germ
and uh like covet it's a virus and what
is what is a virus a virus is dna which
is
encapsulated within uh a uh
proteins okay so that's that's what a
virus is
and uh what this guy is saying there's
something on the outside or within
that he calls microsimus and these
microzymas apparently considered them
living entities he even suggested or
maybe believe that they turn into
bacteria or gave origin to the cell but
the point here is that these microzymas
only react to the environment internal
environment in your side your body so so
he's saying they react to that and
that's why you get sick
okay so
for you to consider okay um it's a
subject i very i'm not very interested
in at all all this medical stuff but
it's for people to consider if they're
going to talk about kobe being a um a
hoax okay is there a virus out there
what is a virus is
the theory of viruses you know causing
disease that's uh is that the germ
theory is that a valid theory
at what level you want to criticize it i
guess yeah okay so this is this is what
people have to look at now i do want to
tell you that we've seen bacteria under
the microscope uh viruses are much
smaller okay about 20 times i think uh
20th 120 is the size of the maybe the
largest bacteria so viruses are
remember virus is a molecule but it's a
special kind of molecule that has a
coating you know it's got a it's got a
coat over it of proteins which is what a
bunch of molecules so we have a molecule
wrapped in molecules and we call that
thing that entity
uh which is non-living according to me
okay uh we call that seems like the
precursor to life it feels like virus
yeah and like there's the thing between
inanimate and anime
okay that's right now we they asked they
asked the the the biologists
what uh is a virus is it a living entity
or is it an inert entity and uh
and this is this these are the answers
we get today from these are all experts
okay these are from the top university
[Music]
no viruses are not alive says one guy
and the other guy says yes viruses are
alive oh that settles it one one's from
edinburgh university of a guy from
glasgow university okay so uh both
scottish here and first one says this is
how he justifies why they are not alive
okay he says the crucial point is that
viruses are not capable of independent
replication
they have to replicate within a host
cell and they use or usurp the host cell
machinery for this they do not contain
the full range of required metabolic
processes and are dependent on their
host to provide many of the requirements
for their replication if a virus is
alive should we not also consider dna
molecule to be alive that's a really bad
uh logic in my estimation because like
we all we all depend on other things for
rep okay that's uh that's what the other
guy answered okay so you got the right
uh reasoning of the second guy he says
they are not alive
he says they are alive he says i would
argue that the only satisfactory
definition of life therefore lies in the
most critical property of genetic
heredity independent evolution okay
evolution he's talking about here life
is the manifestation of a coherent
collection of genes that are competent
to replicate within the niche in which
they evolved viruses fulfill this
definition this fellow david bella he uh
said you know after all we all depend
on something else in other words it's
not like we're all independent
reproducers yeah and uh so this is the
argument
uh between these two but they're both uh
thinking about replication they're both
thinking about replication let's bring
in a third guy okay we're gonna bring in
the third guy who says our virus is
alive they ask another
uh
this guy's from bristol university okay
and so what does he say well he says uh
viruses are not alive because they do
not complete all of the seven life
processes and he mentions those the
famous ones movement respiration
sensitivity nutrition etcetera etcetera
viruses lack essential machinery needed
to what to reproduce themselves
everybody hits on reproduction okay and
that's what they're they're all thinking
about virus is extreme in fact viruses
can only reproduce after infecting a
living cell viruses can only survive for
a while outside host cells okay so
they're all talking about do viruses do
all the other six of these growth
nutrition sensitivity uh nutrition you
can say they eat uh the
uh cell material from the cell and the
viruses but see they don't they don't
really eat it what they do is they use
them the atoms okay because it's at the
atomic level here you have a uh a virus
what is it a molecule that turns around
makes copies of itself from cell
material so it can only function inside
the cell and that's where it reproduces
if you can call that reproduction the
fact that it's producing copies of
itself it's just creating a longer
molecule or making copies of itself
parallel to it so that all its kids are
look like it but all we're doing is
having a molecule that's making copies
of itself using someone else's material
and the first one is movement if that's
if that's what we're going to
say is life okay
reproduction this is what they're all
concentrated on well you know that's why
we have to define what life is i mean
otherwise these guys are gonna because
they've been talking like this for
at least a hundred years they have the
seven criteria yeah but i think i think
that uh
you know
they're they're just gonna go around in
circles because they have all these
factors that they think are part of life
and i think we have to define the word
life alive living a little more uh
stringently okay a little more uh uh
short
uh and not have so many variables there
and say well it's the one that
reproduces the one that ages you know
has children uh moves etc and so um what
is the problem with all these guys uh
i'm saying that none of them ever
defined words scientifically
none of the scientists alive today ever
defined or learned to define words
scientifically and they never found a
reason to define words uh scientifically
in such a way that you know they're
not only that they are scientific but
that you can use them consistently that
you can you can know what you're talking
about if they don't define what life is
they're going to go around in circles
arguing but again the seven criteria you
should have deleted that because the
seven criteria seem to be what they all
hinge their alive or not aliveness on
not really because uh the the one they
really concentrated on was reproduction
i mean that's where they put the other
ones
like the other they mentioned the other
but then they said but forget about all
that we're going to do reproduction
so this is this is where i'm going to
finish this uh
the extension part today and it goes
here like this
none of these folks ever defined the um
disciplines of science and i give you
four examples here what is biology the
scientific study of life that's the
formal definition you'll find out there
study in science we don't study anything
science is not the study of anything
well that's the relief
i mean you can study you can study all
year and not know anything so because
you studied you're a scientist everybody
studies i mean a kindergartner studies
is he a scientist
so the word study should be removed from
the definition of science of any
discipline and you see it in all of them
they're all the studies you're saying
the scientific of life just wrote the
study yeah and the first thing you find
about the word life there is currently
no consensus regarding the definition of
life they have no definition but they're
all biologists and they talk around in
circles of what if a virus is living or
not well because there's also anaerobic
things that we call living and there's
all these like exceptions to the rules
yeah robots count and all these things
there's a rock and so here you have
physics uh the natural science of what
studies matter energy and force what is
paleontology the scientific what study
okay of life that existed prior to blah
blah blah blah blah study of fossils to
what to classify organisms that's stamp
collecting that's not science
all these people talk about studying and
collecting and
uh you know you know what i'm saying you
might defend the word study because that
is essentially what you do isn't it i
don't know i don't study i explain i
explain that you get to the bottom of
physics what is that if not studying but
i could study and i could reach the
wrong answer or or you know but but the
explanation that is explanation is
science not study but isn't it
type of studying no it's a conclusion of
study because
yeah
and then philosophy what is philosophy
the study of fundamentals nature of
knowledge reality and existence no the
study of existence if you want to call
it that is known as physics physics
studies existence not philosophy i think
people study this well that's that's why
here this is why i put as definitions uh
in parallel to that so as you see where
i'm coming from on this okay and uh just
just to mention that philosophy uh you
go to the stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy the only word you won't find
defined uh is the word philosophy they
don't have the word philosophy defined
in the
dictionary the encyclopedia philosophy
at stanford they define their own form
so i had to define it so what is it
science rational explanations biology
explanation involving processes and
mechanisms physics and behaviors
philosophy you know of living entities
living
yeah yeah and now we have a definition
for living a natural object that moves
against the path of least resistance i
used to say it's gravity my son here
corrected me one day and said no it's
the path of least resistance and he i
think he's correct so i hate i hate him
because he corrected me well to be more
specific the reason we use that wording
is at least
going against the path of least
resistance basically is a long-winded
form of saying you move on your own yeah
instead of letting the the wind push you
you push against the wind and and it's
correct because we not only push upwards
against gravity like when i jump but you
know we push against walls uh sideways
as well okay and we also push up like
when we're pushing a box upwards you
know so we're pushing something upwards
you know i guess okay physics rational
explanation of causes and mechanisms
what is philosophy explanations of human
behavior specifically purposes and
reasons and paleontology is that
collecting bones and putting them in a
museum no it's rational explanations of
mass and background extinctions that's
what a paleontologist is out there for
he's supposed to explain death
he's a necrologist he's a um
a medical examiner he's a detective that
has to tell us how animals died in the
past otherwise we don't need a
paleontologist what people want to know
is how did the dinosaurs die don't tell
me that you collected some bones and
gave it a fancy name and assembled it
and put it in a museum that's the stance
collection
yeah they're glorified stamp collectors
i thought that is what they were
okay moving on here let's do some
physics someone said someone says
philosophy is a synonym for religion but
you actually split those two right
philosophy is a synonym no no
obviously philosophy is not a synonym of
religion that's that's exactly where the
area is no no philosophy is a science
science and the philosophy
it's the science philosophy right it's
the science that explains behavior
in other words why you did something
purposes reasons
so no philosophy is not religion
religion is
uh what math does
math moves
first of all recognition but moving
concepts around when you're doing
physics recommendations politics
that's all religion that's religion
recommendations i think religion is
mostly how to recommendation on how the
best way to live is but but philosophy
is more explaining
the past tense of that why did someone
do that
you could get those two mixed up though
because you you could use uh religion to
explain why someone did that oh he had
xyz religion
but i guess that's not that would be
philosophy no no but again
that's a reason why he did something you
could say it's because of his religion
the way he was brought up so you're
explaining his behavior no problem there
but giving your recommendations tell you
how to rule the world you know
politics that's opinion and uh
recommendation opinion uh
that's religion that's just everybody's
an expert in religion in opinions and
business
you ask anyone
sell sell sell buy oh you shouldn't have
sold too early okay uh so moving on here
let's move on to physics
and here i'm just going to recap what we
did this month and that's essentially
went through the um the mechanisms
mother nature uses to do transparency
and opacity i went through at least five
of these mechanisms
and i'm just going to go through them
real really quick i'm just going to
mention first that quantum mechanics has
no explanation for opacity and
transparency why because they use zero
dimensional particles which ain't
particles and they use waves which is
aren't objects okay a wave is a moving
vectors what is a vector magnitude and
direction they have all these vectors
moving so they don't have a physical
object they cannot use the term travel
through moving through
go through they can't do that because
you have to identify what object is
moving through the substance and right
now we don't have an um an object
proposed by quantum mechanics okay okay
but let's look at what we have alignment
is one of them why alignment well here
we did a little experiment okay
and it goes something like this okay
uh
we had two uh polarizing lenses and when
we turned it around 90 degrees to the
other polarizing lens lens uh the laser
uh
disappeared okay it's not on the screen
anymore on the black screen there and
what we're saying is what you see on the
left we're saying when we turn the the
um
what is it the polarizing lens aside
what we're doing is uh
redirecting the ropes in a different
direction it's a really cool effect okay
so so that's uh yeah so that's uh
one of the
ways i'm saying that mother nature does
um i guess you couldn't do that with
water when we talked about well we're
gonna get into that give me a second
yeah here's uh here's the water
alignment okay oh yeah and we have uh
this is
we want to know which which one is true
on the left okay did the water molecules
remain in the same direction with
respect to the center of the earth due
to gravity or did the water molecule uh
stand on its head or on its side okay so
that's the question you gotta answer in
your mind again a question of alignment
but is that why water is transparent is
it because of alignment or is it due to
something else so again i'm giving you
the tools to
figure out why these uh why some
materials are transparent why they're
not there's some hard questions though
yeah it is scratchers okay but uh this
is to make people think okay here's
quantity that's the other uh variable
okay and here we have an example okay
and uh here is when we have many of
something that is transparent and now
we're gonna see when we have only one so
we have a
light there we put a single sheet and we
can see more or less through that sheet
it's more or less transparent or
translucent if you want to use that word
when we put many of the same transparent
materials many sheets you see that you
can barely see the light
so
something that is transparent if we put
many of those it becomes opaque oh yeah
same thing applies to air right
if you look into the distance the the
the mountain is fog
and that could be the smallest it's
blurred oh yeah but smog is the same
thing right
there are particles in the air you know
but yeah that that's the issue the issue
if you put many glasses they turn green
and eventually become opaque so the same
glass that you have
in your window that you can see through
put a a thousand of them and you can't
see through them the same thing applies
to water right if you if you put your
like like a ball under water just a
little bit you could the ball is
basically the same color but if you keep
taking it down down down down it's gonna
start changing the ball changes color
the lower it goes and the issue with air
is the reason is uh you know you would
have to put a lot of air and the reason
is uh because air has approximately the
same refractive index as vacuum okay so
you would need to put lots and lots of
air maybe so far in the distance that to
prove your point that you can't see
through lots of areas and it has to be
clean there you would say well i can't
see that far that's why
okay and then we have temperature is
another variable okay here i made the
example where i took a bunch of uh ice
and i let it melt and you can see that
suddenly the pen appears through the
water so what was opaque became
transparent simply because of
temperature okay now one fell off
pointed out says well in the case of ice
you you're throat freezing also air in
yeah okay
okay fine no problem but see uh
here's another example okay and this is
argon okay
and argon when it's solid or liquid is
more or less transparent
but when argon is in a gaseous state
it's violate it and it's no longer
transparent so it's the other way around
in the case of um
that isn't because it's being cooked or
ionized yeah it's true but i mean the
point here is that um here you have the
opposite effect here you have it
transparent when it's in the solid or
liquid state or more or less transparent
translucent okay but when you heat it up
okay or you uh ionize it well then uh
suddenly it uh
it does it's no longer transparent
that's the point i'm trying to make so
all i'm saying is temperature has an
effect on um
translucency or transparency or opacity
okay i think the temperature one's more
easy to understand
well let's continue because they're
related to that
two things are related to that uh i
mentioned that the other day and one is
stiffness okay so here we have
solid liquid and gas and the issue is
that if you have sound
sound travels faster through a solid
than through liquid and through liquid
faster than through gas okay that's a
really cool gap so so what you have is
sound travels faster so the question is
why would not uh something which is
solid
be more transparent than gas because you
know you would think that light has an
easier time to travel through something
solid than through something that is gas
yes and so the question why doesn't
light travel through walls you know if
if sound can travel faster through a
wall than through a gas
okay so this is the issue
and um and so the question is a question
of stiffness which is related to
temperature okay and so we here we see
here we see a fella who questions and uh
asks uh or makes this comment says i
think light can be compared to sound
okay let's find out light is torsional
and sound is longitudinal yeah okay
and the speed of sound is limited by how
fast one molecule can transfer its
motion to the adjacent molecule we're
talking about molecules atoms right
uh light obviously is not the vibration
of either i like transverse motion yeah
that's a nice way of putting it
the speed of light is limited by how
fast one part of the road can relay its
twisting to the next part how stiff the
rope itself is and yeah i made a point
of saying that you know the speed of
light is a constant i know some people
have problems with that because their
religion goes down the drain the speed
of light is a constant because uh you
know with a rope very easy to explain
you know uh
the number of links is inversely
proportional to the length of a link
and the the fewer links i have the
longer the link becomes and the more
links i have the shorter the links
become and that's what that equation
says c equals frequency times wavelength
wavelength and frequency are inversely
proportional and there you see the ropes
you can see four uh
uh links or semi links eight and sixteen
okay and it turns out that this is
related to how hot something is as well
okay the colder it is the more we
approach you know the infrared and the
hotter it is the more we approach the
ultraviolet okay so
not only do we have frequency related to
uh temperature but we're gonna uh find
out in a second that there's something
else involved okay but here uh
just continuing with this uh
analogy of sound okay
sound is longitudinal okay the the
particles don't travel from my mouth to
your ear the particle that i'm moving
here is not the one that reaches your
ear what's vibrating is the molecule is
close to your ear and that's what you
can hear
yeah so so so i'm not sending you
particles through through the air to
your ear
and what you're hearing is uh
is the motion the motion that i vibrate
just
close to your ear okay
i mean there's always the same gas thing
just tapping on my ear basically it's
the same molecule
if you carry it if you carry it with you
yeah
you know if you stood still it's
basically like a telegram
yeah so uh be aware of that um
and the question is whether that's the
case with um a light here we have a
gentleman his name was uh christian
higgins okay he was uh
dutch uh
uh
philosopher um physicist mathematician
whatever you want to call them i don't
think that they were physicists because
they did more math and physics but he's
the guy who in trade de la lumiere in a
1690 his seminal book he explained how
water waves move and the question is you
know is a water wave the same as a light
wave he thought it was at the time later
on they discovered the transverse wave
that was a
friend now fresnel obviously in front
now he came up with the transverse wave
which was later mathematized by james
maxwell okay a few years later but the
issue is uh you know water waves and
sound waves are those are the same thing
as light waves and like this fella said
one is longitude and no the other one's
not the other one is so-called transfers
it's not really transverse either okay
uh because it's not a standing wave it's
not like you move the rope up and down
okay it's not like that which is the way
usually it's uh
imitated or simulated now what we're
talking about is torsion here which is a
little different moving this up and down
okay
so it's the transverse wave which moves
up and down perpendicular to the
direction of motion of the wave i guess
it's got something to call them all
waves yeah yeah
so i i don't think you know i'm going to
disagree with this gentleman and i'm
going to say that no um
i don't think you can relate sound waves
uh through
because structurally they're different
yeah one one reason why it's up and down
one is not only goes up and down but one
relies on molecules and atoms the other
one is not really that what you're
talking about is a rope
and now we have torsion versus up and
down or back and forth in the case of
sound right in the case of uh water
waves you have this these ripples which
uh heightens explain quite well you know
you have a point source from which a
secondary source uh originates okay a
secondary wave originates from there and
all these are different ways okay and uh
and a standing wave is different than
than really a torsion it's confusing to
call them all waves then you can call
them wave as long as you
correct yeah it is it is
okay uh let's continue here so we
finished by that same notion the
uh newton cradle could also be called a
wave yeah like you don't really think of
it in the term of wave you're not when
one hits the other
goes
okay so uh this was a frequency and
again it's got to do with rigidity
and rigidity has to do with temperature
what are we talking about we're saying
that if you have light coming to a wall
the atoms are stiff there because
they're all in a lattice a crystal
lettuce that you know the atoms don't
move around as much like as air on the
bottom there and so what happens is it
kind of it's a shock absorber and so
what continues is a longer
wavelength and that's why it's beyond
the visible range so i'm saying that
light is is relayed through the cement
wall from atom to atom it doesn't come
out the other side as light into your
eye why because it's got a much longer
wavelength okay in the case of air it
doesn't do the same effect and so
apparently rigidity has something to do
again with why something is opaque or uh
transparent but uh and if you froze air
and made it a wall it would still be
transparent i'm guessing well again i
showed frozen air the other day and uh
it's opaque
okay it turns bluish okay and here you
see uh another example of this and
that's uh you know when you send light
visible light through a prism it breaks
down in different colors that means the
prism which is a solid object is somehow
serving as a shock absorber and when it
comes out the other side the wavelengths
are longer in fact it breaks up into the
different wavelengths such a way that
you get colors what is color wavelengths
i like that microwaves and radio waves
are light that goes through the walls
that's a good yeah good way of saying it
they're invisible light
okay uh and uh final issue here uh
related to this
we say that you can't use quantum can't
use particles or waves because what are
waves waves are a bunch of vectors all
those blue and red arrows that are
moving there those are vectors what is a
vector its magnitude and direction what
are we talking about numbers what is a
particle well the particle of quantum is
not a particle it's not a corpuscle what
it is is a zero dimensional what wave
function collapse if you can understand
that okay it's a field that's collapsed
that because you touched it or looked at
it or whatever why do we need that
reminder though well because to show
that uh for the what i'm going to say
next and that's this people think that
water uh
that waves and particles go through
water and that's not true because before
you can say travel through going through
moving through you've got to identify
what it is that is traveling what is
moving and you can't use waves and you
can't use particles so please be
creative and tell me what physical
object is traveling through
moving through it you can't say well
it's light well yeah you got to tell me
what light is made of
and you can't say particles or waves
transverse waves at least okay so that's
the issue the issues uh if you're going
to use the term travel through going
through moving through
water air
glass no problem tell me what it is what
physical object is moving through okay
maybe you're talking about a ghost
okay
okay let's get down to the
questions people asked okay you got to
give these people priority because they
paid attention and here's one says
consider closing a pair of scissors
the intersection of corner or corner of
where the blades meet is an illusory
object that appears to travel much
faster than the blades do what he's
saying without going through all his
reading here he's saying that if you
take a pair of scissors
and you move like this and the scissors
are infinite okay uh the the blades are
you know the end of the blade is on the
other side of the universe well then the
two ends of the of the blades come
faster together than the speed of light
that's what he's saying
what's the problem i have with this uh
because he's suggesting that um if we
replace the scissors with ropes okay
then he's saying that
the two objects in the distance would
travel faster than light
towards each other other because if
we're doing the scissor kind of thing
but he's wrong see uh
he's talking about something totally
that's got no sense whatsoever the speed
of light is along the rope okay
what he's confusing here is is what they
talked about in uh in several places one
of them is the frequency
frequently uh asked questions of physics
from uh what is it
quora
no it's another it's one of the
universities uh i can't remember now but
the point is uh they said well is there
something that can travel faster than
light and people say well i can imagine
something that travels faster than light
we take off scissors again they're
lengthy extremely lengthy you you put
them together here and over there they
go faster at night one approaches
one blade approaches the other
uh one end of the
blade
approaches the other end of the blade
faster than the speed of light and so
this is or you could take anything for
that matter
you could take a
laser pointing at the moon and suddenly
you pointed you know a jupiter
and suddenly that the end of the that
light traveled faster than light and so
they said what do you mean
faster than light and you can't do that
with with uh
with this with a rope because we're not
saying that uh that there is any speed
limit faster or even slower than light
in other words light always travels at
the same speed
and what we're talking about is
along the length of the rope and not the
scissor mechanism okay so these are two
different things
okay uh here's another question says any
chance for the rope to fully untwist
into two parallel threads well you can
make the assumption that you want
and one of the assumptions i make
you know again this is up to every
person
here the assumption is that there are
two threads that make the whole
shebang yeah no not one no no no no
i think but i think what he's saying is
the fog if you untwist the rope right
then can you get two parallel threads
and and
the first thing is
you as the presenter as the guy
giving an explanation you know uh to a
physical phenomena you can make the
assumption you want and you can make
that assumption you don't have to ask my
permission for that that's one issue the
other issue is that in i make that
assumption that same assumption when i'm
saying what happens
with a rope that extends to the other
side of the universe or from one galaxy
to another in between does it untwist
yeah okay
and then re-twist in the other direction
as it moves onwards
and so uh
maybe this is one of the assumptions you
have to make especially for extremely
long distances
such as uh you know on the other side of
the universe maybe it's one of the
reasons we can't see the stars in
between the stars
because they're so far away because they
at some point it untwists and goes in
the other direction so we can't see that
star because it's untwisted itself we
call them lazy ropes
they're just floating there this kind of
thread
okay another issue here uh oh my god
that's all it says a laser will
partially reflect and partially transmit
well everything that you see in green
there i'll let you read that is uh stuff
that we already know so he just
regurgitates the same thing and he's not
addressing the issue so
the issue is not any other things that
he mentioned there okay what's the topic
and the topic has to do with um
um
you know when uh a one-way mirror you
look at yourself in the mirror
and uh you see your reflection it turns
out that the person on the other side of
the mirror
they can see you and you can't see them
because you see yourself and they see
you
they don't see themselves it's a one-way
mirror and so so the question
this is the issue he's not addressing
the issue all he's doing is just
regurgitating what is already out there
and it has nothing to do with the
question at hand what is the question at
hand the last comment that he made there
he says a material appears transparent
when it does not strongly uh absorb or
diffract light
okay so this is the issue the issue is
absorb light what does quantum say well
quantum says what you see on the bottom
there you have a photon that red ball
and it hits the electron in a um in an
atom this is what quantum says okay if
if it hits it with enough energy that
the photon jumps to the next energy
level the photon is absorbed if it
doesn't have enough if the photon
doesn't have enough energy to boost that
electron to the next energy level then
it continues through or is spit out
again by the electron whichever one you
want and
the material is transparent so here's
the million dollar question that this
fellow doesn't want to answer now this
is three times now he doesn't want to
answer because he can't answer the
question first of all
and and so he alludes it saying oh i can
answer the question no he never did and
this is the question this is the million
dollar question he's got to answer and
until he answers this question all he's
doing is just uh eluding it okay
we have the guy who looks at the mirror
he sees himself the gal looks at the
so-called
mirror which for her it's a glass and
she says him
is the is the uh
glass coated yes
is it a question of lighting on her side
and his side yes those are not the
issues those are not at all the issues
that we have before us what is the issue
the issue is the thickness of the glass
keep in mind we're trying to answer the
quantum question we're saying that a
photon hits an electron and either has
the enough energy to knock it to a new
energy level or it doesn't if it doesn't
it goes through and if it does it gets
absorbed that's the issue that we have
to address and here we have two lasers
on the bottom we have one on one side of
the glass the other one on the other
side of glass we're only going to look
at the photons that make up the laser
not the ones that make up the room not
that what make up the glass or whatever
we're only looking at the photons of the
laser okay
yeah both lasers and the question is is
the material they have to go through the
same
in either direction
is the material
are the number of atoms the number of
molecules the same in either direction
and the answer is yes and so the
question is why is it absorbed because
that's what quantum says okay
quantum says that uh the electron
absorbs if it
absorbs the photon then it doesn't go
through well here we have the same
electrons in both directions why does it
absorb it in one direction and not in
the other and it's got nothing to do
with the lighting in the room or the
coating on the on the mirror so don't
don't use that issue again they both
have to go through the same amount
not only the same amount but the same
type of material is just one
hits
the one is absorbed the other one is not
well not at all but here in this case um
the light coming from one direction hits
the surface of a diff the first
material that the light hits is what
makes it reflec reflect or refresh right
it's got nothing to do with the material
that constitutes the entire glass
because it should in either direction
you know it should it should be absorbed
or not because that same atom that uh
absorbs the electron the photon coming
from the left should be absorbing also
the one from the right and why does it
absorb it
okay why does it absorb it in one
direction and not in the other direction
that's the question you have to answer
and if you can't answer that question
please don't don't you know don't insist
because you've answered the same thing
three times now you know and you haven't
answered the question
okay so i just want to make sure we got
that one straight okay
wait did you answer the question
uh no i didn't answer the question um i
just gave you the example that
quantum mechanics has an irrational
explanation for why
it's transparent in one direction and uh
opaque in the other direction the
irrationality
consists in that the electron of that of
one atom because they should absorb it
should absorb in either direction
because they both have to go through
that exactly and so if it doesn't absorb
it in one direction you got to tell me
why
it absorbs it in one direction it
doesn't absorb it in the other it has
nothing to do with the coating has
nothing to do with the lighting in the
room it's got to do with the religion of
quantum mechanics that says a photon is
absorbed by an electron well how does it
work on the rope model
ah that's what i left for as homework
and i'm not going to be yourself
[Laughter]
okay so i'm going to skip the question
out i want people to think out there i'm
giving you the tools
what are they alignment okay uh
temperature uh quantity of material okay
so you have this i'm giving you all
these
and you have to apply those to glass
water air and find out why those are
transparent why a brick wall is not but
both quantum and the rope model
both have to explain why
going through the same amount of
material yeah doesn't
lead to the same outcome you got it
that's basically it we have to all
answer that question that's a question
for everybody
okay uh two more issues here and then
we'll open the floor for questions here
it is
fella says getty scientific method is
not without problems oh okay let's find
out what the problems are uh it
uncritically assumes the existence of
objects
yeah we're going way back okay so this
guy does it with uh ghosts and goblins
and phantoms and spirits i guess that's
how he thinks that uh the universe runs
he he thinks that because a pen
you know falls to the floor
i'm assuming that there's an object that
pulled it down and he's saying no
that's a wrong assumption so what is he
going to do it with with uh ghosts and
goblins okay is that what
physics is about
introducing black magic okay
so yeah he mentions the the uh
establishment's version quite well but
again he's just a religious individual
that's all he is okay if you're gonna
you're not gonna assume objects then
you're you're introducing black magic i
mean
you think this is kind of like a given
okay but here we have uh let's talk
about like the matrix or something where
it's all on our heads or something it's
all virtual
yeah i guess but but here we have even
worse people this fellow says it is a
most uh a moot point that light
determines the speed of limit in the
speed's limit dielectric force is the
cause of the gravity effect so now the
homework for you is to guess whether
this guy is a flat earther or univer or
electric universer
i mean
anyone who says that electricity is
gravity which is what this guy is saying
well you know he belongs to one of these
two groups and so your job is to figure
out if this guy is a flat earther or a
electric universer
could be both okay what questions do we
have today let's find out not that many
i noticed okay good
it means we retire early
today or we answered all the questions
we have a lot of
more statements and people's opinions or
other questions
what does jf say on viruses do you know
jfs yeah jf well remember he's uh uh
he's a biologist or claims to be a
biologist uh i tend to disagree because
a biologist is a person who has to
define the word alive because you know
biology is a person who explains things
related to living entities and if you
don't know what a living entity is
because you never defined the term then
i don't know if jf can tell me
whether uh what is a living entity and
so i don't know what his answer would be
first he has to define life then he can
tell me whether a virus is alive or not
and he would have to justify it through
his definition uh this wasn't a question
but it is a question i'll pull out of
the comments and do rich people have
bunkers in new zealand where they will
go to when the [ __ ] hits the fan well i
don't know if they do but if if they do
have bunkers the big problem there is
that are they going to have servants are
they going to take their servants in
there like you know the ancient pharaohs
used to take their servants with them to
death uh well you know their servants
don't have to respect them once they're
in the bunker okay because they have no
way of of controlling their servants if
their servants are young and they're
supposedly
whatever to protect them you know i
don't know how they're going to control
them what are they going to give them uh
money
uh is the rope good to hang with
yeah
i had to get there yeah yeah clothesline
you can hang anywhere
yeah we talked about that yeah i mean
that was pretty much it we have a lot of
questions here i mean you can go through
them later if you want them answered but
they don't seem very okay folks here we
haven't addressed your question either
through the lecture or here well now we
have you here at the end you do have
some uh do you have friends watch
lectures of your father uh yeah
sometimes we watch them oh you do watch
i mean our criticisms are more um
how he you know the um's in oz
but not really not really about the the
do you still have friends after
i don't show them very often
i mean physics debates in my friends
groups tend to i mean we don't really go
there no but but you do you do i mean uh
you get once a year tops but even then i
don't know every time i go to lunch with
these guys
[Laughter]
yeah we end up talking about extinction
and physics surprise surprise he's the
type of guy where any conversation
either leads the end of the world uh
light or what's his last one magnetism
something like it always ends up in one
of those
uh okay well we'll uh if we haven't
answered your question just ask it in
the uh comment section in the when did
we put up the video bill how are you
part of the last generation when you
have progeny on your right
you're not last year the [ __ ]
it's heavy last
we'll see you next time folks
bye bye